Hello, this is Jim with next level
And no, this channel hasn't been taken
over by Ugu. I'm perfectly safe and
stable. I have survived being mind
controlled by Anesthetist
Emrakul. Yeah, and I've got videos about
the
Muxus gang and
no, I mean Homer the Hermit Homer the
Hermit coming up. So look forward to
those. But before that, today's video is
to wrap up the Ugu trilogy. But it's not
about Ugu, it's about picking cards for
your deck, especially ones with
seemingly thousands of options like for
example, you know who you go. So we'll
talk about the individual card choices
why we are omitting some of the
flashiest, most powerful options in
favor of boring role players that no one
even plays anymore. Also, I just passed
5,000 subscribers. So we're doing a
sweet giveaway with my sponsor Kakapopo.
If you want to win this awesome deck
Bento or the Monsters Den deck boxes,
stick around. Now, if you're just
interested in the giveaway, you can also
jump to minute 10 to see what's in line.
But if you stick around, I'll go over
with you how I sifted through hundreds
of excellent card suggestions to find
the perfect ones for my deck. And it can
be difficult with how open-ended Ugu is.
Almost all of them are excellent
suggestions that can have some sweet
effects on the deck. But I have to say
no to most of them because well, you
know, my commander is Ugu and not Wits.
And actually, I've been brewing with the
Muxus gang and I'm I'm facing a very
similar problem. It's an embarrassment
of riches that forces you to really
think about what the core of your deck
is. I think it's helpful to visualize
your deck like a tree where you have the
trunk which supports everything. Like
that would be your commander vegetables
like ramp, card draw and the cards that
directly synergize with your commander
to generate an advantage that other
decks don't have. This is our top
priority and once we have that, we move
upwards to what many consider to be the
fun part of the deck. The synergies, the
clever little interactions, the win more
cards even. But if you've seen my deck
techs, you know that I like my trees not
looking like this, but more like this. I
want my core to be as solid and as
consistent as possible before reaching
outwards to the front part. Let's take
the example of my Ares God of War deck.
In this deck, I've got the core strategy
of constantly dropping hasty little
creatures and getting them back into my
hand with the help of a cycle. To secure
this core strategy, I dedicated 28
cards. And only then I begin reaching
upwards. Hopefully this FIFA style
coloring makes sense. Green means cards
that are directly connected to the core.
And these are just one level away, so we
can usually pull them off pretty
consistently. But then if we reach up
another level, we have cards that we can
pull off less reliably, but are smashier
and oftentimes more fun. If you look at
cool but rude, the second level is one
of the main reasons we're playing it,
but it only works best if we can
reliably fire off these draw effects
from the level below. Personally, again,
I'm very careful with playing these
cards, especially if your deck and
strategy isn't really short on
playables. My Gitrog deck, for example,
has 48 card slots dedicated to elves and
pump. That's the core strategy. And my
Evelyn deck is the most extreme example
of this with 59 cards enabling the
blinking and cloning of Evelyn. Now I
know many will consider this to be
boring, and this is absolutely a
preference. I choose to do this because
I want my games to be as consistent as
possible. I want my decks to
consistently do something every game
rather than having swingy experiences.
Like sometimes I will have a million
damage with while sitting at 200 life,
and then have games where I do nothing.
And with that in mind, I think I can
begin justifying what I choose to play,
and perhaps more importantly what I
choose not to play in Ugu. So, the core
of the deck is clones and reanimation
spells. The clones will help make
exponential Ugus. Meanwhile, the
reanimation and undying spells serve as
cheaper but more situational clone
effects. And at the same time, they
serve as protection for Ugu, which this
entire deck leans on. Fairly simple and
straightforward, and I have over 35
cards to ensure that my core game plan
happens. And again, as mentioned
earlier, this game plan it gives us a
ton of different directions to go when
it comes to synergy. And all of them are
just one step away from the core,
whether it's devotion, tribal, tokens,
or something fringe like convoke. But as
you may already know, my favorite
synergy here is the Arcane Adaptation
effects because miraculously, thanks to
the interaction with clones, these also
synergize directly with the core game
plan with no need for intermediaries.
Now, this is usually not the case for
these effects. For example, my friend
Alex has an Altered deck. And that uses
Conspiracy to turn everything into
Assassin. When it works, it's absolutely
glorious, but when he's denied the
Conspiracy effects, the deck falls flat.
So, history is much more top-heavy than
mine. And that's because Altered is kind
of limited in terms of its ability and
also the tribe. And Alex is crazy. But
fortunately, with Uku, we have enough
directions and card choices to not have
to step outside of the core circle. And
we get to be pickier when evaluating
potential inclusions, looking at
different factors like opportunity cost,
for example. And yeah, that's the first
thing I look at. For example, Banana
Senpai mentioned Shifting Woodland. I
didn't even need to read his excellent
justification. I just alt-tabbed to the
decklist and added it. Well, partly
because I know how powerful this card
is, but more importantly, there is no
opportunity cost. It's just a land.
Similarly, Red Fox Zhu Wu recommended
Fur Dad Core. This one is much, much
trickier because there is actually an
opportunity cost. There will be times
when I draw this in the opening hand and
wish that it was the land or else that I
cut for this. But it's not that far off,
and the end game potential is glorious.
So, I believe it's a yes. So, yeah, if a
card can closely resemble another card
that you already have, it's much easier
to include. For example, C'Thunia
Nightmare. In 90% of the scenarios, this
is basically an enemy dead for our
commander. So, I can just replace an
Undying effect, but the potential upside
is just massive. So, yeah, this one goes
in. Another example is Grave Sifter.
Now, in the comment, Astriomashes
mentioned the synergy with
Omni-Changeling. The two together
straight up wins the game. And that's a
pretty good upside, but the floor here
is much lower than cards like C'Thunia
Nightmare. It is generally only good in
the late game when I have a lot of mana
to take full advantage of the card
advantage it generates. This is
completely different than Reanimate,
which is a cost-efficient add-on to
clone effects to improve our tempo in
the early game. In the opening hand, I
would love to see a clone and a
reanimate. But, a clone plus grave
sitter is much less exciting. Well, this
one is a little bit more costly than the
ones we've mentioned earlier. So, for me
it's a maybe, leaning towards no.
Another great example of this is
Insidious Roots. When I saw this
mentioned from Black is Color, I
thought, "Wow, this is perfect. How did
I miss this?" I make a bunch of tokens,
I have creatures leaving the graveyard
with all the reanimation effects. So,
this card feeds itself and can even be a
win condition. But, after some thought,
I ended up picking Enduring Vitality
over this. And this is because the Elkin
enchantment has a much higher floor, or
in other words, a lower opportunity
cost. In a pinch, Enduring Vitality is
inexpensive mana dork, and also turns
the original Ugu into another.
Meanwhile, Insidious Roots requires us
to have finished at least the first
phase of our game plan to do anything.
For this deck, the early game is
definitely a bit of a bottleneck. So, we
would rather have cards that help us get
through the first few turns of the game
than winning more later on. The
suggestions of Doppelgang and Mondrak,
also kind of fit into the same category
of cards. And on that note, I decided to
follow Terra Plant's advice to swap in
lower cost ramp options with higher risk
and less value to help accelerate our
early game. So, with that in mind, you
can see why I have to pass on the
suggestions of Sedec and Zu Ifit. These
are both cards that are relatively slow,
but generate a constant stream of value.
Same with the likes of Mycas and Driven
Out. The one that really tempted me
though was, surprisingly, a background
suggested by Matthew Guritz. Again, a
few hoops, but this can do a decent
undying spell impression, and at the
same time doubling the power on our
board all for three mana. This one I'm
actually very tempted to test. Another
difficult one was suggested by Carlo
Andre Set, Blade of Souls. This has
potential to generate a lot more tokens
than just a clone, and it goes crazy if
you also have an undying effect. Plus,
you can re-equip it onto new creatures.
This is like a card made for EDH. So,
without context, I might call someone
crazy for playing the ancient outdated
clone over this. But, with everything
mentioned so far, you might just be able
to see why I'm making this choice. And
with a card choice this tight, you can
probably see why we don't have much room
for anything beyond the first level. For
example, the land landra archmage, which
does cool things when we have arcane
adaptation. Same with something like
ghost vacuum. Faces of the past was also
mentioned to combo with earth craft
effects. But once again, these are like
two levels from our core strategy, which
we will have to dilute to accommodate
for cards like these. I mean, for how
disciplined we've been, there's
definitely some room for pet cards. So,
yeah, by all means, play what you like.
This brings us to the next criteria,
impact. Despite being very conservative,
if a card has high enough sheer impact,
we are willing to jump through some
hoops or take a little bit of risks.
Joseph Jones did a great job explaining
the crazy skilling of glade walker
ritualist. Now, to do all of this, the
card requires us to have a board of ugus
and the cycle lid. But yeah, the sheer
payoff of this is really difficult to
say no to. Chopping changeling and
especially acidic slime are similar in
that sense. So, all of these are solid
inclusions, but on the flip side, there
are also cards that have simple, direct
synergies, but not enough impact. There
are those from this comment over here.
For example, fatal shriek, burning one
target opponent for one life per
attacker just isn't quite enough. I
mean, we are in the colors of gray
merchant. Also, metallic mimic. In a
tribe that is more aggressive and
desperate for pump, maybe, but not here.
So, yeah, card evaluation here is
actually fairly simple. Everyone knows
to look at the upside, the potential
Christmas land scenarios, but it's just
important to keep in mind the hidden
cost of replacing a piece from your core
game plan, even if it's with something
that is just slightly slower. Hopefully,
that makes sense. And you know what else
makes sense? A giveaway when you reach
certain milestones like 5,000
subscribers. Honestly, I never imagined
this when I started my channel in mid
2025. I actually thought it would be
closer to 50,000. But what keeps me
going is realizing that whatever it is,
it's not just a number, but actual
people who I share a passion with. Ones
who love the game and deck building as
much as I do. Honestly, getting all
these suggestions was amazing. And I
would love to continue to hear from you
in my future videos. Luckily, my sponsor
Kakapopo TCG agrees with that. So, in
the future, there will be a giveaway for
every single video, but this one today
is the biggest. First off, we're giving
away two Monster Stand Deck Boxes. Now,
I've been using these since before I
started the channel, and they're holding
up beautifully. And the design, I mean,
see for yourself, it's pretty sweet.
These I'll actually be given away to the
commenters of my two previous videos,
Ugu part one and part two. The only
criteria are that you've commented there
and subscribed to the channel. The
winners will be chosen randomly. these,
I will do the cut off right now, when
this video goes live. So, if you haven't
commented there, don't bother, unless
you really want to. But more
importantly, I've saved the grand prize
for you in this video, the Kakapopo Deck
Bento. And this one I've been using for
almost 2 months now, and the aesthetics
is so unique. Video doesn't even do it
justice. It's got this super elegant
design with striking patterns, and it
even has this cloth to wrap everything
up. And it's just awesome how they put
so much thought into these designs, and
they offer so much more, sleeves, dice.
Click on the link in the description to
see pictures of the grand prize, but
meanwhile, you can feel free to browse
through the site, see what they have to
offer. If something there catches your
eyes, good news, I also have a discount
code, levels, all caps. Use that when
you check out. So, how to win this Deck
Bento? Literally, just be subscribed and
comment on this video, anything you
want. You can I mean, I'd love to hear
about your approach to deck building.
Are you as conservative and pragmatic as
myself, or are you the more greedier
Magical Christmas Land type of player?
Or just comment anything. Hi.
What's up? You suck.
Yeah, and you're in. And the winners
will be announced not in the next video,
but the video after, so roughly in 2
weeks. I will also reply to your comment
notifying you, and if you don't see it
in time, I'll wait for you. I mean, I
have the products here with me, so yeah,
can't mess that up.
Okay, this is Jin with Next Level
Commander. I'm done with Ugu, I promise,
but I'll be making more videos about
legends from the Mystery Booster packs,
and and they're also pretty amazing. So,
I'll see you in the next video.